the thing about Ford that I love is that
we're focusing on bottom up people you
know people love to talk within the
binary of the left and the right and
we're not left or right we're forward
and people are like naturally their
minds wants to wants to go we're middle
they're middle they're middle but
they're we're not necessarily middle
we're literally going to communities and
going to people
and letting them
figure out policies where you know we're
presenting data innovative solutions
seeing what works seeing what doesn't
work what solves the homeless problem in
La is probably not going to solve the
homeless problem in Lexington Kentucky
and it doesn't mean that one solution is
conservative and one's Democrat it
literally just means that they're
Solutions
thank you
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to forward the finance director
for the forward party late of the
democratic party Kate Sayer welcome Kate
thank you Andrew it's nice to be here
yeah it's great to be with you you and I
have shared so many experiences already
over the last number of months road
trips here there cram crammed into a
little compact car yeah we drove between
cities uh together we looked and said
you know what why fly when you can drive
yeah no one's driven the one between San
Francisco and L.A
yeah I mean yeah Pacific Coast Highway
it's a delight so you made a very very
significant move from the Democratic
party to the forward party uh so thank
you for doing that but glad you have me
yeah but what prompted that huge career
move for you yeah it was definitely
uh it was it was both an easy and a hard
decision I was getting more and more
disaffected with the Democrats been
working there for a long time
um with some high up you know Democrats
did some like did some Consulting on my
own uh worked for a couple you know
non-profits advocacy groups things like
that
um how many years were were you almost
10 years well yeah so I started in a
congressional level and have worked uh
state and local as well so
um all campaign stuff mainly
really enjoyed what I was doing but got
into politics to do something positive
and I really started strongly feeling
like I was not doing that anymore
um I had told myself
after 2020 I was going to give the
Democrats one more cycle and I was like
and then I'm gonna figure out what to do
because I'm like if I leave the
Democrats like I'm not a republican so
I'm not going to go to the Republicans
I'm certainly not a Libertarian I
wouldn't go there and so was like I
guess I would just like find some sort
of non-profit to just kind of like sit
in and and I and like watch America
collapse
um dark but yeah
um but luckily uh forward was launched
um read your book had followed you from
the presidential uh but didn't run into
you on the trail or anything but uh
followed you from the presidential read
your book listened to an interview with
Barry Weiss and was like
this seems where I'm at and if this is
going to work it's going to be it's it's
got to be this and it's got to be now
and uh one on the website and literally
the only job posting was the one that
fit exactly what I do so uh applied for
it well actually I wrote a cover letter
sat on the cover letter for like a week
or two
kept sitting on it had a bad day where I
was
and was like
I'm done I'm done with the Democrats I'm
done I'm leaving
drink a whole bottle of wine and then it
says
and here we are now so I'm glad I did
that yeah I I remember when Matt uh got
your application and he mentioned to me
he said hey we had a really really
strong experienced applicant uh for the
finance position and I was like oh
that's fantastic to hear and then when I
had a call with you I was like wow she
seems amazing
um so what you said it was both easy and
hard what was like the easiest part and
the hardest part
the easiest part was reminding myself
who I was as a kid and what I got into
this career for
and saying
this is this is what I want to do like I
want to be able to help America I don't
want to keep you know spinning my Wills
the hardest part was that this was my
career and
I mean you know very well and people who
have left to come to forward know very
well the two-party system is very
entrenched and so to leave
a party especially when you make it your
career uh and you know that's how I live
yeah was terrifying so it was the idea
of you know knowing if I leave I more
than likely
could never go back and uh so was very
scared and you know I meant I'm uh I
care a lot about America but I'm also
you know personally ambitious person and
so it was weighing kind of
I guess it was weighing
the risk of it and I
um and ultimately I was like you know
what I don't care if it's a if it's a
risk it's a risk worth taking so well
super grateful that you took that risk
and I have to say that your position is
shared by a multitude of other people
and if you make your living in one party
or another leaving is terrifying yeah
I have um lots of friends who work
actually both in the Republican and
Democrat uh system so friends on the
Republican side and on the Democratic
side who have privately told me
I am jealous that you left I don't think
I could do it I need to make my living
I can't piss you know the right people
the these people off and I hope
everything works out and and good luck
and I'm like oh have some courage but I
also get it and I'm I'm lucky enough to
not have a family that I have to support
so I didn't have to think about like
children and all that stuff and I do
have friends who do have to think about
that so I I give them a little bit more
Grace but not that much grace because
don't they want the country to be better
for their children I appreciate your
courage and character and fortitude a
great deal because uh there are many
many people who got into politics for
the right reason
but then have found it to be a bit less
effective and more cynical than they
might have hoped in their younger years
uh but then they're stuck it's a you
know hey I've been doing this for eight
ten years I have some seniority I have
some experience I mean one person who
made a similar uh call is in the Next
Room is Joel sierby
over from uh from the other side but
it's a similar
experience where you lose a lot of your
professional contacts you lose a lot of
the value Network that you spend years
and years building up so I'll say to UK
too grateful but also it's one reason
why we're going to make this work at a
grand scale because character should be
rewarded in my opinion and I will say
too that when I left the Democratic
party uh I didn't think it was going to
be that big a deal
uh little did I know you underestimated
that yeah I suppose I did underestimate
that but but it's something that uh I
actually got a call from uh someone I I
admire and respect a great deal who
called me up I'm not sure I've ever told
the story
uh it's like maybe two days after
um I leave the party and uh you know
there's a bit of a social media like
brouhaha and then he called me up and
said hey man I just wanted to say it is
great to actually see real life human uh
courage
and so like just want to express my deep
admiration for you this is someone that
I admire and so that meant a lot
uh
but I hadn't realized that it was going
to be a thing
um in part because I didn't really make
a living yeah in the same way
and so it's one reason why I think what
you did is 10 100 times more admirable
and uh principled and courageous then
yeah thanks I I would say though it is
it's very helpful for people like me
when people like you publicly leave
because it creates I it adds more
credibility to it you know your public
figure whereas I'm not and so uh having
having that in my back pocket is people
are like oh okay so this is like a thing
happening oh it's a thing it's a thing
oh yeah we're making the thing oh yeah
thank you
guess what just came out on paperback
it's forward out on October 4th you can
buy it in any bookstore near you and if
you use the promo code Yang you get
absolutely nothing this is your chance
if you were waiting for a cheaper
version of the book it's on October 4th
pre-order it I really am proud of this
book uh it's something that you have to
read to believe all right forward out on
paperback thank you everyone
[Music]
foreign
a lot of disillusioned upset people on
the Democratic side oh yeah uh and one
of the things that we have to make a
distinction about is that
like I I want the same good things to
happen for people now than I that I same
as I did when I was a Democrat yep same
as you it's just we think that this is a
more real effective way to make those
things happen in real life rather than
be someplace else where you're
advocating for it but it may or may not
ever happen in real life but you're
going to make money whether or not it
happens oh yeah I mean I sat there and I
watched
the messaging
work in a way where you were
incentivized to lose on issues so that
you could win re-election campaign off
of it you know point the finger at the
other side the other person both sides
do this but I you know I didn't want to
be party to that I was like I want to be
able to vote for something and not
against something and at the same time I
want to be able to vote for something
that I think they'll actually work
towards doing and there were very few
times that I actually saw that happen
for the most part they just put up
policies that they knew were going to
fail
so that they could just campaign and
raise money off of them and that's just
it was
very heartbreaking and frustrating
one of the main reasons why the
Democrats might uh
outperform or be competitive in November
is the Dobb's decision yeah and so in a
way there this is like winning by losing
it's like well we fail to protect
women's Reproductive Rights but it's
going to be a great rally in Cry For Us
in November and that's exactly what they
did I mean the next day and there was
some stuff that you know I really
commend gen Z for kind of calling the
[ __ ] but uh because it was mainly
Jen's ears out like protesting and
saying like but I'm also getting texts
from Democrats asking me for money and
it's like you had 50 years to do this
why did you not protect me and it's very
interesting when I talked to my liberal
friends uh you know and I'm pretty left
as it is but when I talk to them I'm
like I get why you're like oh no I have
to vote for the Democrat because they're
the only pro-choice one and I'm like
yeah but are they railing pro-choice
because they didn't even try and get a
basic thing passed because if you look
at like Europe a lot of the abortion
bans and stuff are after you know 1922
weeks things like that and if we had
come up up with something like that at
least
you can at least start there to where
your you know someone in Mississippi
isn't completely screwed and and we're
but they decided not to because it's
easy to campaign off of yeah they tried
to pass a bill that Republicans would
never go for oh yeah and there were
moderate Republicans who are raising
their hands being like look if you do
something middle of the road like I'm
into it yep uh Susan Collins Lisa
murkowski there were multiple Republican
Senators saying like we can pass
something that codifies Roe v Wade in
the basics but the Democrats did not put
that bill forward and they didn't want
to yeah they're they're it's it's very
much a symptom of A Dysfunctional
two-party system oh absolutely it and
and I don't want to like just sit here
and say like all these politicians are
evil and and calculating because I know
a lot of them they're really actually
good people who who also got into this
for the right reason for right reason uh
but then
as you get more and more into the system
you know you don't want to lose your job
you start telling yourself you're
actually making a difference like it's
it's rough and then you're like oh no
I'll win this one and then I'll actually
pass it and then you're like wait no I
need to win this one so I'm not so then
I'll actually pass something and you
just keep justifying it to yourself and
it's very and it's heartbreaking this is
the fundamental truth of it Kate is that
it's easy to paint folks in the system
with a brush and say oh they're corrupt
they're bad but a lot of them are good
people yeah who showed up and were like
hey let me do something positive the
problem is that they get stretched in a
dozen different directions by this
incentive structure that ends up
pounding them down and and uh diluting
any ability to have a positive impact
Ezra Klein wrote in his book why we're
polarized toxic systems compromise good
individuals with ease yeah and that's
really what's happening absolutely yeah
and it
honestly like one of my favorite moments
in history is the American Revolution
and I love the founding fathers
um have since I was a kid I have a kite
and a key on my arm for Benjamin
Franklin and it makes me
very sad to see something that they
would never have wanted happening I mean
how many of them warned against a
two-party system
and wanted an actual functioning
democracy and a republic I mean a
republic if you can keep it and
I really hope we can keep it but I think
it's uh up to forward it's coming down
to the wire for sure yeah
okay real talk everybody
how are your sleep habits because
honestly on a personal level
I used to struggle sleeping or I just
wake up in pain or wake up with like
back creaks Etc and then
honestly I got a helix Sleep mattress
and like it sounds too grandiose to say
it's life-changing but it was frankly
pretty life-changing it's a premium
mattress brand that offers tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences they've got like 14 unique
different mattresses and how do you know
which one works best for you you take
this quiz you take this Helix sleep quiz
and for me it's like do you sleep on
your side sleep on your back do you
sleep hot you sleep cold do you put
weight on this that sort of thing it's
pretty basic it's like two minutes and
then bang they give you a personalized
mattress selection and then shipped to
you straight to your door free of charge
there's no better way to try it as they
know
by sleeping on it yourself so you can
sleep on it for 100 nights free
risk-free there's 100 nights try it out
if you don't like it they'll pick it up
full refund no problem I love this thing
I love my Helix it's fantastic they're
American made they come with a 10 or 15
year warranty depending on the model and
you get to try it out for a hundred
freaking nights risk-free so right now
for our listeners a full word you're
gonna get Helix offering you up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows which is nice so those are for
our listeners go to Helix sleep.com
slash Yang so helixsleep.com Yang get
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
foreign
so you got into Democratic politics to
do good things uh and you had a deep
personal set of experiences that drove
you in this direction you grew up in uh
would it be fair to call it Appalachia
or yeah part of it was Appalachia then
Central like Central Kentucky uh yeah
yeah so you left the country when you
were a teenager but had to come back
because of unfortunately like a a really
tough family experience yeah when uh I
had always wanted to move to England
since I was a kid I think it had
something to do with the Spice Girls and
Harry Potter got a job right out of high
school in England which was really cool
also they hired an unqualified person
but hey uh take it so I move over there
and pretty much immediately two weeks
actually after I moved my brother got
shot and he got shot in the head
I consider my family one of the lucky
ones because he actually survived but he
got shot in an area that has
severely changed you know his life and
our lives it has dictated a lot of stuff
in our adult lives I was only 18 years
old he was 19. so our entire adult lives
have been you know
my brother who was this person before he
got shot and is this person after he got
shot and you know there's still lots of
the same my brother there we joke we we
have the same jokes we you know
reminisce a lot of stuff but
areas of his brain are don't function as
well he is paralyzed uh in his left arm
and somewhat in his left leg it makes it
hard to work it has driven him to
worse drugs to In and Out of of the
prison system
you know uh
hard to hard to hold a job as a as
someone who is both disabled and
formally incarcerated
and is in this country and uh and so
you know it's been a struggle but
I yeah it was a huge moment I actually
had never was always political growing
up I actually grew up a democrat in
Kentucky which is unusual yeah
artistically at least yes and it made me
uh a contrarian on a lot of things one
issue that I didn't think much about at
all growing up was Guns just because it
was Kentucky I was around them and never
really cared for them but didn't like
hate them
and then to watch my brother get shot
after you know he lived I knew he was
going to walk and talk again I moved
back to England to fulfill my job
um obligations and then was there and
like witnessed a completely different
type of relationship with guns people
had hunting guns and and other things
there were there were parts of cops like
that didn't have guns only like a select
group of their like police force has
guns because their populace isn't armed
yeah so they don't have to like fight
with their populace that ended up
becoming my main political driver
after you know after I left England when
I started working in politics really
focused a lot on on like gun
I don't like calling it gun control like
gun violence prevention I went to I went
to college uh in New York City and I
studied uh political science and then
was part of the Hunter College Roosevelt
program and so I was a I was like a
Roosevelt scholar thing you have to like
apply to get in and you write a policy
paper and mine was literally on
gun policy in Kentucky and I focused a
lot on intimate partner violence
actually uh when I did the policy paper
and so much can be changed and actually
when you pull people
that's like what they want so it's
pretty it's
it's pretty interesting
that I could see both where the
where some sides would block legislation
but then where other sides would try and
pass extreme legislation in order to say
the other side of blocking legislation
and then nothing common sense or
protective can get done and then these
people are are like literally dying and
and you see that in opioid policies in
prison policies and Health Care policies
and it's just over and over and over
again there's a middle ground of Common
Sense policies that most Americans would
agree on including folks who in what
you're saying are Avid gun owners yeah
who was would accept certain regs that
they see as
even-handed and rational yeah and some
of them it's possible that you can own a
gun and still be concerned about partner
violence suicide any of a host of things
yeah absolutely and where there's like a
high level of veterans in Kentucky and
Veteran suicide is a huge deal and uh
and people legitimately care about that
it's just there's a whole lot of I just
constantly go back to the systemic
issues with our two-party system and I
just constantly kept seeing that so when
Ford came along and offered an
alternative I was like I had I mean you
have to do it we have to build it yeah
so you worked in Democratic fundraising
and you worked at every town for gun
safety yep yeah I did I I actually
started every town for gun safety as
just a volunteer and uh was a I was
working in politics but was doing every
town on the side and became a Survivor
fellow so I would speak about my story
and talk to you know news and and
volunteer groups and Advocate advocate
for people and you know start help start
the Boston chapter which was really fun
and then
the option to be the Midwest political
director came up and I got that job and
I did that for the 2020 cycle which was
really interesting because it was the
middle of the country which is a very
difficult place to be running
um on gun policy so but we supported you
know it was nice supporting
Democrats and Republicans we had to find
we had to work really hard to find
Republicans and then
it was just kind of dealing with with
the system that I just kept seeing the
dysfunction of the two-party system even
at the local level because we worked on
elections up and down the ballot and
just seeing just how
in how entrenched it is like you can't
even say certain things because you know
you identify as red or blue and and you
have to like watch what you say and you
have to you know only vote in one way
and it was just it was you know
devastating so it was it's a very
frustrating thing because I care very
much about the issue yeah clearly I mean
you've been
working on it for years yeah you know
but personally and professionally I
started realizing
all these issues I cared about I mean
whether it was the environment which is
some which is actually how I got my
start in politics I started teen
environmentalists of Kentucky when I was
a teenager a lot of these things are
just not going to change until you
change the incentive system the
incentives are not going to change until
you get rid of the two-party system it's
an absolute Nightmare and it's the
reason that we're that we're where we're
at now I mean Trump people like to point
at Trump and say he was like he started
this it's awful blah blah he's he's an
absolute symptom of the dysfunction
foreign
from our sponsor betterhelp look I'm
checking in how's your mental health
folks because with everything going on
in the world and social media and things
getting more expensive inflation
political Dynamics going nuts or just
day-to-day stress it's important for you
to talk to someone and I found times
where I'm focused on problems and not
Solutions where I like my brain spirals
towards the negativity and that's why
better help is awesome it can be tough
to train your brain to stay in this
problem solving mode and for me having
someone to talk to help me do that so
here's the deal I tried this out I got
my better help counselor it's online
it's easy schedule when you want you
just pay per month you don't pay per
session so that they don't can't rack up
the fees that way which is great and if
you're thinking of getting therapy
better help is an awesome option it's
convenient it's accessible it's
affordable and it's entirely online so
get matched with a therapist after
you're filling out a brief survey and
you can switch therapists at any time so
here's the deal when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there so visit betterhelp.com Yang
today and get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com Yang I love this stuff go to
therapy try betterhelp it's great
[Music]
the fact is the two-party system might
have made sense at a particular point in
time but it's not making sense at some
point in the last number of years and uh
you you know this where the the two
parties were ideologically quite similar
for about a hundred years yeah it was
like vanilla versus French vanilla and
then they started to diverge uh in the
60s and then that's just accelerated
over the last number of Cycles
one of the fascinating things about
forward
is the nature of the people that have
joined and your profile I think is uh in
some ways
a great example where you grew up in
Kentucky
uh you went to school in New York you
worked in Democratic politics uh in New
York and Boston you also worked in the
midwest in Democratic politics you right
now live in Kentucky
and you're exposed to people all the
time who are kind of not in like one
bubble or the other yeah and I was on a
fascinating email chain yesterday with a
bunch of forward party
leaders and a surprising number of them
had connections to the working class
where it's like oh I'm the first in my
family to go to college oh I'm not the
first my family that that's a
professional and so they all ended up
sharing this and it ended up being a
very very
consistent thread and they were actually
surprised at each other they were like
oh I didn't know you you had this in
your background uh you kind of straddle
the these worlds uh
when so first do you think that that
actually is something that brings people
to forward and second what was your
experience within one bubble or another
because I feel like you kind of uh are
very fortunate you kind of bridge Both
Worlds yeah uh
friends here
uh if I can get it right but he said
right now it
two parties are just this group of
elites on either side who don't give a
[ __ ] about the regular people
and
I was like holy moly that's so true and
that's where I think you're seeing like
these Working Class People but that's
also why you saw
Trump had this weird way of even though
he you know not a working-class guy he
comes across as a working class guy but
also like listen to them and talk to
them where a lot of people just weren't
talking to them and that's and so did
Bernie Sanders and that's why you do see
some and I mean even you did that and
that's why you do see some of like
Sanders voters move to Trump I think
some of your voters moved to Trump and
and it's it's this disconnect of elitism
versus you know non-i guess non-elitism
but like we're people not sitting in
their Ivory Towers and you connect very
well with them Sanders connects very
well with them unfortunately Trump
connected very well with them he has
this weird ability to sound like he's
telling the truth even when he's not but
um actually during that election I was
living in New York City
and
you know I did some stumping stuff for
Hillary in in different places uh
through some of my clients and
when I would go back to Kentucky very
rarely but to visit family or something
and I was just talking to people I was
like Trump is
he's tapping into something
the good news is these people are not
all deplorables like Hillary said yep
there are people who are sold in him and
it's just not going to change but there
is a good group of people who just
want to be listened to yeah they want
things to change they're not necessarily
even super far right if you talk to them
policy wise no like they're like free
Universal Health Care but they just like
have nowhere to go and I think forward
is providing that and it's providing
that in such a positive way where it's
not inciting anger and violence and and
it's really giving these people a place
to go and it's it's given me a place to
go a lot of my friends want to come over
and it's really interesting and so
being in the two and then the second
part of the question the two bubbles
were just so strange especially during
the Trump years going back to Kentucky
and being like
listening during the primary too where
people are like oh well like iffy about
Trump and then by the time he won the
Primary like completely sold on him like
in love with him and then Hillary said
the deplorable thing and they were like
even more sold they were like you're
gonna call me deplorable because I'm
thinking about voting for this guy
you've sold it I've got it this is who
I'm voting for and then coming back to
New York I remember I was I was working
full-time and in school full-time I took
a
the long way through college
um but I was sitting in class
and someone was talking we were talking
about environmental policy and Trump had
just won and everyone was still reeling
but you know we were just trying to get
through class and everything and you
know middle of New York City Upper East
Side
and this girl in my class was like have
you guys ever even seen SUVs like what
are the point of them
and I was like you are the reason Trump
won like I was living I was like have
you ever been to anywhere else in
America other than Manhattan because
SUVs are useful and
people who have three kids kind of need
them or a van and we should be working
on policies that make better SUVs for
the environment and promote American
jobs in making those like electronic
cars and other things like that not
shaming people who drive SUVs out of
necessity and so I was
and like jumping from Bubble to bubble
and it was very strange because back and
then people were shocked back home my
best friend worked for Mitch McConnell
back then and so uh she left shortly
after Trump was elected but um she she
was a field rep in Kentucky for Mitch
McConnell and I'm over here working for
like a prominent Democrat and people are
like how are you guys best friends like
and when I say best friend she's like my
sister and uh and we're like because
we're normal human beings who can have
normal discussions and we love each
other and we agree actually on a lot of
things and it was always people were
always just like whoa no way and at
first it was endearing to some of like
my clients and then after a while it was
like wait no we have like the other side
is evil they need to be painted as evil
we don't associate with them blah blah
and I have my problems with Mitch
McConnell like don't get me wrong but
I'm not gonna sit there and call my best
friend evil
[Music]
foreign
was that there were people who uh were
on the outside looking in who felt like
I was
trying to help them and I've reflected a
little bit on why this was or is
uh and part of it is that I was clearly
not of the establishment and I think a
lot of these people just feel like the
establishment is looking down on them
and doesn't give a [ __ ] about them and
absolutely and because clearly the Asian
dude is not like you're not gonna send
the Asian guy who wants to give him
money yeah uh so so that that was a part
of it but there was another thing that
really spoke to me and touched me where
I ran into a supporter and her mother
Avid Fox viewer and said that Yang was
the only Democrat that she'd support or
consider supporting
because he's the only one who doesn't
seem like he's judging me yeah and uh so
much of of Trump's appeal is that he
seems like he is listening to or
speaking for people who
don't feel like they're seen or heard in
American Life
uh and I naturally
felt like these were folks that
democrats should be representing and
fighting for because most of them are
working class and I had this uh view in
my mind that it's the waitress or the uh
former manufacturing worker that are the
lifeblood of what the Democratic party
should be about when I was out there in
the Midwest and found out that a lot of
those people did not like Democrats it
made me sad honestly but there's
something
uh there's something that we need to
help capture which is what you said is
that look we just want to make things
better for regular people yep uh and
this system is separating folks into
these factions when really what is
making us angry and miserable is shared
by both the mom and Harlem and the
person you know the the struggling
family in Kentucky or West Virginia like
it's the same stuff it's just that this
system is pitting us against each other
so that we're all gonna lose yep and
we're also told that there's only one
solution right like
people in you know the struggling mom in
Harlem
and the struggling farmer in Kentucky
might be dealing with similar issues and
like both dealing with you know
systematic problems on getting a job or
battling corporations that kind of thing
Child Care would have you child care
things like that but the solutions there
in rural Kentucky versus Harlem are
going to be different and and that's not
a bad thing no that's a good thing and
what the way that we structure
politics now because the parties have so
much control is they'd basically say if
you're a Democrat you must believe these
things they must work in the rural
Kentucky and in the Harlem which by the
way gives up on 70 of the country
geographically because your stuff's
never going to fly in you know most
rural areas which like at least by land
mass is is most of the country yeah and
so and and the thing about Ford that I
love is that we're focusing on bottom up
so we really I like we're not people you
know people love to talk within the
binary of the left and the right and
we're not left or right we're forward
and people are like naturally their
minds wants to wants to go we're middle
they're middle they're middle but
they're we're not necessarily middle
we're literally going to communities and
going to people
and letting them
figure out policies where you know we're
presenting data innovative solutions
seeing what works seeing what doesn't
work what solves the homeless problem in
La is probably not going to solve the
homeless problem in Lexington Kentucky
like they're just two different places
and it doesn't mean that one solution is
conservative and one's Democrat it
literally just means that they're
Solutions yeah and that's why and so
there has there has to be a new approach
yes to policy and solving problems out
of the binary out of the binary yep I
will confess to you Kate uh some of the
things I want
to see in the world are pretty far out
yeah I just don't think that our current
political system has any interest in
delivering no no a whole host of things
not at all and and forward
offers an opportunity because we support
things like final five voting open
primaries ranked Choice voting as we
move through these states and these
cities and these localities
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to fight to open the system so some some
of my friends who are like sick of both
sides they're like I'm done like these
Elites don't care about me where do I go
I'm like you know what come to Ford help
us open the system up yes and then if
there's six parties and you fit better
with that party over there leave because
right now you don't have that choice
yeah but right now literally no option
yeah and so and most of them are like
oh yeah that makes sense okay and it's
like there you go great yeah yeah uh
yeah I mean we just have to take this
message out to people as quickly and
effectively as we can in different ways
because a lot of people you know that
they're they have their uh hands full
just kidding by and and you know you
have to make it work for them and
relevant yeah uh so thank you again for
being such a
Patriot person a character like a real
leader thanks uh I've really enjoyed
spending time with you everywhere we've
been yeah it's fun yeah and you and I
are two of the primary figures
responsible for making sure that forward
gets uh the resources it needs
no pressure
great yeah I mean we have a lot of help
but yeah you know we also have our fair
share of work to do uh so if you had any
guidance or advice for someone who wants
to learn more spread the word get
involved yeah you know what what do you
say to because it sounds like you've
been doing a great job with your friends
yeah uh go to fordparty.com sign up I
actually when I'm just wandering around
Kentucky I'll go I live in this small
town right outside of Lexington now in
Central kentucky I go to the local bar
all the time and most of them are
trumpers most of them think you're cool
most of them love like what uh when I
talk to them about open primaries final
five ranked Choice voting they're like
yeah that makes sense oh that's fine
like that sounds good I would vote for
that and I'm like of course you would
and then I go into Lexington which has a
more blue like it's red but has a more
yeah and uh my stepmom actually is very
very involved with the community in in
Lexington and and all run into people
with her and they'll be like well I'm
traditionally Democrat and or I you know
I vote Democrats specifically because I
don't want to vote like only because I
don't want to vote for like Trump's
party and I'll be I'll just talk to them
about forward and actually my stepmom's
doing a good job of doing that too but
let's talk about Ford and they'll be
like Oh I'm sold I'm done and like right
then and there people just like sign up
for it so
uh so yeah so fordparty.com that's the
best way you can sign up
um and learn more information and and
you know figure out what you want to do
but there's so much to do and
we have active people in literally all
50 states it's pretty wonderful it's
insane I and I've worked in in politics
a long time not as long as everybody
else at Ford but uh or some of the other
people at forward but I have seen
enthusiasm come and go on waves you know
on the Democratic side I've never seen
enthusiasm the way that I see it with
forward and I I'm getting this you know
I work a lot with donors and I'm I'm
getting some of this from donors but
then when I deal with like the
Grassroots people when we do events when
when we're traveling I'm just like Blown
Away the people want this they want it
so bad and the people who don't have
time to volunteer and stuff who who
maybe stop by the events or who I talk
to in Kentucky or you know whenever I'm
traveling and just talk to randomly they
want it they want it bad and they just
want to like know when it happens so
then they can just be a part of it
so I I feel the same thing Kate and I I
feel this responsibility to bring this
to them yeah well because the the
average person and and here's the thing
it's like you have these two behemoth
parties you know like multi-billion
dollar parties and then we're like the
scrappy upstart people okay guys let's
like fix the system like let's try and
align the incentives like do this thing
and the average American uh needs to get
frankly like tapped on the shoulder and
be like hey like there there is this uh
race there's this thing in your
community it's going to be relevant to
you uh and so we just need to build the
org to a point where it arrives in their
Community whether that's like a local
event whether that is like a school
board or city council or Congressional
race or whatever it is but I I feel very
very much in my bones that uh if we
bring this to them then millions of
Americans and you know I get thanked
every day just walking around people are
going that because there's like this
Instinct that people have yep still that
there's like this machinery
and then we're trying to build something
outside of the machine to improve the
the machine and so folks who are not
that politically engaged just sense that
we're trying to do something positive
and they just come up to me
every day and and sometimes I can sense
that they don't really frankly like know
the ins and outs
yeah but it does that they just says
that we're fighting for them yeah it is
come up and you're just like hey you
know thank you for for what you're doing
yeah absolutely I mean I love walking
down the street with you sometimes and
and seeing when people get excited and
and especially when they're like forward
man forward and I'm like yes it's so
great it's actually like one of my
favorite uh moments although I do love
the random people who are like scared to
approach you too I think those are those
ones are really funny oh yeah I'm I'm a
fairly friendly guys you know
sometimes when I'm trying to get you
from place to place too friendly I'm
like stop taking pictures we gotta go we
gotta go well well Kate I'm so glad that
you uh
uh decided to join us you made us better
and stronger every step of the way and I
learned a ton from you and we have a lot
of work to do but you're going to be
like an enormous part of us getting
where we need to go yeah it's it's been
wonderful thanks for you know taking a
chance on me like I took a chance on you
guys and did you take a bigger chance
than we did it's been great though
haven't regretted a single day so I have
loved every second of it and I can't
wait to keep going
[Music]